mmm you have your y equals log X here
and the question is simply want to post
you is what's that area I've shaded this
area in green it's an area underneath
the curve just like you normally deal
with how big is this area okay now not a
trick question if I were just to think
about this as in a simple terms as I can
it's an area underneath the curve so I
would normally form for a weird curvy
thing like this I'd normally form an
integral okay now what integral would I
form that would exactly in one hit give
me this area can you tell me what my
upper and lower boundaries should be one
two three very good because even though
I haven't told you because you know what
the function is you can work out what
the x-intercept is over here that's a 1
so therefore you start at one your end
of 3 no problems it's just an area under
the cursor no PI's involved or anything
like that no rotation what will come
next what's the integrand it's just long
X that's what you're interning and it's
with respect to X because it's beneath
the curve that is the integral that
would give you the exact area there's
just one teensy problem which is that we
don't know how to integrate logs it's
very tempting like a lot of students
will say oh I know what to do with this
I know what happens when you have logs
it's 1 over X right and then they get a
really nice simple answer just happens
to be wrong that's all what have they
done they have done something we've all
done in this class very last couple
weeks
they have differentiated instead of
integrating and I've even had students
come to me and argue they've said no but
you can't integrate log X so this is the
only other thing you can do with it and
just forget the fact that has nothing to
do with the answer so if this is a
common error we do not want to do it but
our brain is kind of cornered what can
we do with this if we can't integrate
log of X now there's a big fat clue on
the board right now it's the title what
we want to focus on today is about
integrating exponential functions and
ways that you can use exponential
functions and their integrals for areas
even like this there's an exponential
function hiding in here it's not obvious
but the
but I'm trying to wave a red flag and
tell you that it's in there somewhere
should make you think where is there an
exponential function hiding in this
question and you takes it thinner and
what do you see up here the nur is
noticed this is a log and a log is just
an exponential just viewed from the
other angle right two sides of the same
coin I could rewrite this and I
encourage you to rewrite it as X change
that to be the subject being equal to as
through said e to the Y yeah it's
exactly the same I've just rewritten it
it's a little bit weird writing X as a
function of Y rather than other way
around but this this is much more useful
to me because really good at integrating
exponential functions logs not so much
you can actually integrate log functions
for extension to students but it hurts
your brain when you do it so I'm going
to avoid that delicately and do
something that's actually in the tune
and extension one's syllabus how is this
gonna help me this is what I want to use
over here right this is a function of Y
now so won't do much good to be able to
integrate that with respect to X because
it's a function of Y so what would
happen what area would I get if I took
this guy and integrate it with respect
to Y where is it on the board yeah when
you're different sorry when you
integrate with respect to X you bound it
bind you make an area with the x-axis
does that make sense if you integrate
with respect to Y you make an area with
the y-axis does that make sense so
here's the y-axis over here if you've
got another color with you or if you
want to like I don't know crosshatch it
in a different way this over here that
was not very straight line this guy over
here is the area I will get if I
integrate with respect to the y-axis
does that make sense now it's not the
area I want this is the area I want but
I can get to that area from this one
yeah I'm gonna need some help before I
do that though it's an area with respect
to the y-axis so I'm gonna need some Y
boundaries yeah the bottom one's easy
what's the bottom Y boundary
it's still zero that's convenient but
the upper boundary I have to work out
how do I work out this value up here
yeah I'm gonna take in the corresponding
x value it's three and since this curve
is y equals log X then this is y equals
log three so now I have a value up there
yeah so now I'm ready actually saw my
question how all the pieces I need the
area I actually want is equal to now I
could go and do like a couple of
different equations here and say the
orange area is this the green area is
that but we can do it all in one fell
swoop if I want the green area but I can
find the orange area what's the what
happens when you put those two together
you just get this rectangle right what
are the dimensions of this rectangle how
wide is it it's three units across see
that zero into three and how high it's
only three do you see that so therefore
I can find that rectangle that's how
wide it is that's how tall it is and
then if I want the green area I will
what am I gonna do I'm gonna subtract
the orange area so subtract the orange
area that I'm about to find is that okay
you just told me the Y boundaries from
zero to log three and in here I'm gonna
write the function of Y right which you
guys told me before to help this out
it's e to the Y dy is that okay just
before we move on notice how this is
this forming this thing was all the hard
parts right
you've got Y boundaries you've got a
function of Y you're integrating with
respect to Y everything works yeah let's
evaluate it three log three is still
hanging out the front doing not very
much at the moment take away what's the
primitive of e to the Y it's just e to
the Y oh I love these exponential
functions is so nice to do it okay
you've got your upper and lower
boundaries zero to log three we're
almost there subtract now don't forget
you're about to put everything in here
after this minus sign
yeah so everything gets the minus sign
applied I'm going to put some big fat
brackets here just to remind myself of
that
okay now I'm gonna do my upper and lower
boundaries here are the other one upper
ones a to the log 3 actually that's it
it's pretty simple isn't it
take away what's the lower boundary into
the 0 really didn't need this breakfast
you know there's that double negative in
there watch out for that because you're
gonna expand out a second 3 and a log 3
take away what's II to the power of log
3 that's just 3 you see how important
all those exponential and log laws that
we index and log Wars that we learned
last year were so that's just three done
well there this guy this is one there's
a double negative there here is my
answer
almost what's it missing it's it's an
area so there is my area how do you feel
when you have a look at the actual
calculus of it the actual integration is
the easy part right it's all the form
it's like the the geometric thinking and
the formation of this integral that's
the tricky part and the rest of it just
kind of falls out